Hi, we're back.
So I've been wondering, how you know
if somebody is a good collaborator,
right, because these candidates
when they get their job,
they have to work with other
people on shared code basis.
So how do you know from a GitHub profile
if somebody is going to be a good
collaborator?
>> So one thing I do to screen people
for how they'll work well in a team or
how well they work on our team,
is to sort of branch out from the GitHub
profile and maybe start with the issues
on the repo that they've participated in
and see how they've participated
in those threads and
if they've commented in on poll requests
and whatnot and just get a sense for
how they interact with other
engineers in the repo.
Particularly one thing that I think is
really interesting is, whether they're
patient with the kind of people who may
be newer to the community and then from
there, let say you branch out and maybe
find if there's an Internet Relay Chat
channel that they may have been related
to a repo and look at the logs and
just see, are they're helpful,
are they kind, or are they patient and
it's such an important signal because at
the end of the day, you really want to
hire people that are going to work
well and be a good fit for your team.
So yeah, I spend a lot of time doing
that, just kind of digging in and
seeing how they interact with
other engineers publicly.
>> Yeah.
So when you're talking about interacting
with other engineers publicly,
you mean on open source projects, right.
I know personally, it's very daunting to
start working on this big library and
all these other really
intelligent people working on.
So how would you start, or what's your
advice for a beginner, a new programmer,
to actually start contributing
to these open source projects?
>> It's a great point, Matt.
It's really daunting even for me,
and I know one thing that I do and
that I recommend people do to
just sort of break the ice with
a new project is like find some
documentation, even the ReadMe.
One thing I love to do is actually go
through the ReadMe, clone the project,
try to build it, try to get it running,
following the steps in the ReadMe, and
then like try to clarify it based on
the sort of problems that I have,
maybe it just needs to
be updated a little bit,
submit a poll request with
a few changes to the ReadMe.
Those almost always get accepted.
[LAUGH] And
it's just a great way to break the ice.
I mean, you're going to move
on to actually fixing bugs and
then maybe actually contributing
features, but just to sort of get into
that community and get over that
initial hump of feeling intimidated and
there's just so much code and
not knowing where to start,
I find contributing some documentation
is a great way to start.
>> Cool.